okay uh welcome back for the last talk
of today and i'm uh delighted to
introduce my colleague chin lee
who's going to talk about rcd and lmc uh
and that's random randomized coordinate
descent
and uh logic by monte carlo okay take it
away thank you um thank you very much
for having me here it's really my great
pleasure
um to have this opportunity to
demonstrate the collection of our work
during the past two years i would like
to talk about random coordinate descent
and lmc laundry monte carlo this is just
to incorporate random coordinate descent
as an optimization algorithm into
laundry monte carlo as a sampling method
so random coordinate descent as an
optimization method it improves over
gradient descent
in the numerical efficiency and we would
like to see when you incorporate the
same strategy this concept into lmc do
you see the same improvement
um
so the during the last two years
or so
um we have experienced a lot of upturns
and downturns so um given the speed of
the development of this field and the
density of smart people in this area
it feels like a roller coaster to me but
uh finally at least today i think we can
say that we have the full recipe of the
understanding um so it's a it's a review
type talk i'm going to give you a
collection
um different ways to incorporate random
coordinate descent into lmc and we're
going to discuss the pros and cons for
different methods
okay so this is a joint work with my
student gia he gave a talk yesterday
already and i think he impressed some of
you and he's on the job market he's
looking for a postdoc position
um
gentle has been helping out a lot and
a special thanks to steve who introduced
us to rcd this concept
okay so the core question the core theme
of the talk is how do you sample from a
distribution function that's also the
core theme of this whole workshop and
there are many aspects to look at this
problem and our
our perspective
is to enhance the numerical efficiency
when the dimension is high
um
so the frameworks that we have we are
going to incorporate random coordinate
descent into language follow so in some
sense
random coordinate decision is our key to
the problem
um so let's quickly go over
the concepts
learn the monte carlo it can be regarded
as a discrete version of language
dynamics that is to say that you write
down the stochastic differential
equation and the stochastic differential
equation the invariant measure is your
target distribution so develop these
terms very strategically you you you
exponentially converge to the invariant
measure so lingerie monte carlo is a
discrete version of it so
ideally it exponentially converts to the
invariant measure as well
up to the discretization error at some
point your discretization error dominant
and that is a term that tells you how
your algorithm depends on
kappa
the the conditioning of the problem
excellent the accuracy and d the
dimensionality of the problem so usually
it's algebraical
and our product our problem is um
whichever language multicolor that you
use it usually requires a full gradient
for each iteration
and we think that's a a lot of cost
so let's uh take a
look over damped laundry monte carlo
is uh andrew
the method developed from the overdamped
landowner dynamics so this is your
stochastic differential equation you
have two terms balancing each other one
term drives you down to the to the
equilibrium to the to the minimum point
and the other term gives you the
fluctuation
and when you do the discretization you
march forward uh by descending along the
gradient and on top of that you add a
brand new motion term you add a gaussian
gaussian random variable
and we know that
for the convergence the number of
iterations you have to pay
is
a
d to some power over epsilon to some
power and this power can improve if you
have better regularities of f
okay
so our question is over here in each
iteration you march from one to one
sample to another sample you have to
compute the full gradient
the gradient it has d component you have
these those many partial derivatives
that automatically add you
another d to the cost and we think b
squared is too much we would like to
reduce that
so the same story is for the underdamped
london monte carlo the language the
endoderm to london montreal is derived
from under the london dynamics and the
landmark the way we look at the
endurance ender dental and drama monte
carlo is
the spring system
so you have x dot equals to v and v dot
equals the friction term
and the um the the potential term when
the potential term is not x squared you
have an extended version and the
spreading motion basically gives you
some fluctuation on the velocity and the
acceleration
so you oscillate and eventually you come
it comes down to the equilibrium
so
on top of this endoderm electron
dynamics we have the androgen android
monte carlo method
conditioned
on the previous iteration solution x m
and v m you march forward for x n plus
one v n plus 1
then this the new iteration solution is
a gaussian random variable with
explicitly computable mean and
explicitly computable covariance matrix
so you draw your sample from this
gaussian
also for absolute accuracy the number of
iterations you have to pay algebraically
depend on d and epsilon
and the same story that in each
iteration you have to compute the full
gradient
and we think that's too much it
automatically adds you d those many cost
so we would like to remove that
so that's a summary both over damp and
android and lambda and monte carlo has a
pretty high dependence on the d when you
think about the cost
so we usually view the ph inference or
variation sampling method as an extended
version of the optimization
you can either view it as the
optimization over the function space or
you can view the algorithm is to
optimization algorithm adding the brand
emotion term
so whenever we encounter some difficulty
in the variation sampling we go back to
optimization and ask have we encountered
similar difficulties and what are the
strategies that we have over there so we
took out our toolbox
and asked what are the algorithms over
there that help us to reduce the cost
the costs come from the dimensionality
when you compute the gradient
so that's where we come up with the
random coordinate descent
the random coordinates descent the story
goes back to the classical algorithm the
gradient descent the gradient descent
says you want to compute the minimum of
a function then you descend along the
gradient it can be viewed as a discrete
version of this ode
the same story in each iteration you
have to compute the full gradient
and each gradient has d components you
have to compute the partial derivative
and that's a lot of cost
so the random coordinate descent is
simply to say how about in each
iteration i look at my d those many
coordinate and i just select one and
update only that one i keep everybody
else untouched
so i only compute one partial derivative
and remove or set the other partial
derivative to be zero
um
so of course immediately you see that
the cost is saved per iteration from d
dimension to one dimension so per
iteration the cost is reduced by d
already
however it is not immediate that random
coordinate descent is eventually going
to win
so so in order to descend in order to
find the minimizer eventually every
coordinate need to be updated
so if in each iteration you only update
one coordinate you have to pay d those
many iterations to get everybody updated
so although in each iteration you save
by default you have to iterate more
times so it's not immediate that
rcd eventually is going to weigh
so there are some dedicated analysis
over there and eventually we do say
that the random coordinate descent
weighs in some sense
so the cost of the gradient descent
because of the gradient the number of
iterations you have to compute is l over
mu with mu being the convexity
coefficient and l being the lipschitz
constant for the gradient
and on top of that because in each
iteration you compute those many partial
derivatives because this much so that's
a very classical result
and random coordinate descent says the
cost is almost identical you still have
the d dependence you still have the mu
dependence but you replace l by l max
what is our max so you write down h as
your hessian
the mu as a convexity is a lower bound l
as the lipschitz constant is the upper
bound and l max is simply the biggest
entry along the diagonal
the biggest entry along the diagonal of
the hessian that basically indicates i'm
looking at the stiffness of that
particular coordinate in the objective
function and picking the biggest
stiffness
so
is proved it can be it can be
demonstrated that l max is always
smaller than l that is basically saying
the random coordinate descent is always
going to be cheaper than the gradient
descent
and in some situations l can be as big
as d times l max so if you plug it in
you basically have a d square l max that
basically means in this situation the
gradient descent is going to be
defaulted more expensive than the random
coordinate descent so in some in some
situations you can find a random
coordinate distance saves by a lot
and we should emphasize that
well
both these inequalities are sharp uh yes
please
randomly
get the same feeling
one by one oh yeah
yeah there are there are algorithms like
that
yeah of performance
any difference yeah
uh we didn't check that
actually i was just asking about
four yeah
oh yeah
yes
put it up here
thank you
uh
for optimization
uh i actually don't know
if you did not choose the coordinates
randomly but just went one by one right
in order right you know the first second
third
uh
uh there is a slight problem the the
coordinates get chosen not completely
random each coordinate gets chosen with
different probability it depends on the
stiffness of that coordinate
the answer is no there are kind of worst
case examples where scrolling through
the coordinates in order is worse
but in practice they're usually pretty
much the same
yes
so um for the results that are shown
is it with high probability or um
because the algorithm is randomized so
so how do i interpret the results
expectation
okay thank you
should we continue
um
right so
so we were saying that both inequalities
are sharp that means you can find
examples that make this both inequality
holds true so in the first case that is
when the hessian is a diagonal matrix
the diagonal matrix basically means each
coordinate it depends on itself so you
take the gradient with respect to me i
cannot tell you any information about my
neighbor when this happens the biggest
spectrum happened to be the biggest
diagonal entry as well
the second situation is slightly
tricky
i think it's it's more
manipulated when the hessian looks like
this this is essentially say every
coordinate is playing the same row in
the objective function this is
essentially x1 plus x2 plus xn squared
so every every coordinate essentially is
playing the same row so when you take
the gradient with respect to me i can
exactly tell you what is the gradient
with respect to my neighbor so gradient
descent is paying actual effort to
compute the same redundant information
so of course gradient descent is more
expensive yes
so yeah i'm curious does your randomized
coordinate descent induce more bias
okay
what do you mean by that
for example if some of the coordinates
are chosen
uh
a lot
well the others are not
some coordinates are chosen more
frequently than the others yes
yeah we're getting back that to that
yeah okay thank you i'm looking forward
to it yeah thank you
oops
right so this is a summary that random
coordinate design always says
um and sometimes it can be defaulted
cheaper
and we asked as a question when we
incorporated coordinate descent into
laundry multi-color
can you say
the same thing about the saving
so let's uh let's take a look
so this is what we had before the
overdammed and underdamped both of them
requires a computation of the gradient
and random coordinate descent is saying
that in each iteration i just randomly
pick one coordinate and i say i only
compute this coordinate and everybody
else get kept the same
and i denote it by capital f
so we just put it in right
so this is my original formula for
overdamped laundry monte carlo and this
is my new formula random coordinate
descent lmc immediately we encounter
difficulties
so we have the gradient get replaced by
capital f
then what do you do with a brand new
motion term
the first thing you can do is keep it as
it is so that's a lazy choice we give
you the lazy name random coordinate
descent lmc
um
so
so when this happens you you take a step
back and think what what is happening
so the the the mechanism for random
coordinate descent to weigh over
gradient descent in each iteration you
randomly pick one coordinate
so on average if you take d iterations
then everybody sort of get a chance to
descend once
but
if you keep the bromine motion as it is
this is essentially saying that in each
iteration you pick one random coordinate
to descend but everybody fluctuates
right so after d iteration every
coordinate descent once but everybody
oscillate d times so you're adding a lot
of arbitrary like redundant oscillation
in there so the intuition actually tells
you if you do that this is going to give
you a worse
performance
we're going back to that later a quick
fix to it is to say in each iteration
i pick one coordinate to descend and
only this particular coordinate get the
oscillation the brownian motion and
everybody else keep untouched
so when this happens we were basically
inheriting what random coordinate
descent is doing for gradient descent so
we expect the same saving
in the sense that the d dependency is
the same but the l dependence the
condition independence gets get chosen
in a better way
so this is a summary when you do random
coordinate descent into lmc we expect
worse result
and when we choose random coordinate to
do lmc we expect similar results and
what the random coordinate decision is
doing for land for for gradient descent
okay
so
let's justify it i would like to give
you some confidence first so let's go
with choice number two so this is to say
that each coordinate get oscillate once
after these steps and descend only once
so we have exactly the same assumptions
the convexity is mu the lipschitz
constant gives you the upper bound of
the hessian the hessian has the biggest
diagonal entry and we have the upper
bound and lower bound of l and l max
the result we have is the following
so in comparison to the classical
overdamped laundry monte carlo which
cost for the cost is d squared l squared
the new result that we have when you
choose a random coordinate version is d
squared you replace l by l max
well they have the summation of blah
blah blah and you you take the maximum
that's a you're replacing l by l max so
this is the same behavior that we were
expecting to have
the d dependency is the same but l
dependence get replaced by l max
therefore depending on the conditioning
of the problem you may have some saving
um
so
um
this is a reference from two years ago
and this paper is kind of a singularity
of this whole community in the sense
that it has a very special way of
proving things which they they reduce
the l square to l and we haven't seen
these techniques in using any other
references and we cannot really follow
that technique either
but nevertheless you can still imagining
there are still situations where else
max square is bigger and smaller than l
okay
so
the explicit statement of the theorem is
the following so let's get back to that
so
x m is your m situation sample and q m
is your probability investors and two
distance
the probability converts to the target
distribution exponentially fast which is
expected
up to the discretization error
and this discretization depends on the
convexity and the step size
and also depend on
the electric constant per direction
and p i
is a probability for i's coordinate to
be chosen
and now we have the explicit format of
the discretization error so we can
minimize it if you minimize this error
you'll find out if pi the probability of
ice coordinated to be chosen is
proportional to the sleeper's constant
this term is minimized
and accordingly you can compute the
numerical cost for the iteration for the
convergence to epsilon
i just mentioned that the step size
is also accordingly adjusted
if
a coordinate stiffness is high
l is high then the probability of this
coordinate to be chosen is high
the associated to that in each step when
this coordinate gets chosen the step
size has to be small
so on average everybody march forward at
the same time scale so the step size h
is one over p i
yes please
so how do you know the value of li
oh that's a good question we don't
this is only for theory
yes
but the algorithm needs no
i was
yeah how can you actually run the
algorithm
you have to do some sort of estimation
to make it practical i guess you make
assumptions basically yeah
that's true
um
so a fair comparison is um when you do
laundry multi-color
without this li information you you need
your step size to be smaller than one
over l over there anyway and you don't
know anything about that l so you make a
guess
yes
so let's move on to over depth at the
end of them
and they don't do the same story we want
to replace the gradient
by the partial derivative that is to say
everybody else kept untouched and picked
one coordinate to be updated conditioned
on the previous information the new
update is a gaussian random variable
following the mean and covariance you
can explicitly compute it and over here
you have the partial derivative so
that's cheaper per iteration
the result is the following
so the under damped classical
underdamped result has the d dependence
being three halves and l dependence is
also three halves
so when you do the random coordinate
version of the endoderm the d dependence
get kept the same but l get replaced by
l max so in the same story because l max
is always smaller you always get a
cheaper algorithm but l is or sometimes
can be d as voted more expensive
defaulted big so you'll get defaulted
cheaper
so the exact statement
of the theorem is also the same you have
the exponential convergence in terms of
the resistance distance and you have the
discretization error and now in order to
control the discretization error this p
i the probability of each coordinate get
chosen is l i to two thirds
we don't know why but this is what we
got
so also
if your coordinate is steve you get the
chosen more frequently and you have to
adjust the step size h accordingly
so we put it on our table
this is exact resemblance of what we
have in optimization new optimization
random coordinate decent ways
by you
when you when you're when your
conditioning of the problem is
interesting
and simply we also have the same
behavior
so
good
um
so i'd like to remind you that
previously we had a bad choice
we believed that
um when you choose the gaussian random
variable to be a high dimensional random
variable in the sense that in each
iteration
one coordinate descent but everybody
oscillates when that happens intuitively
we believe it's a worse algorithm
and we would like to see if it's truly a
worse algorithm and if it's truly bad
then what is a mechanism that makes it
worse
so the answer is yes it is bad and
so this is a result from over from the
over-damped to the random coordinate
descent over them the d-dependence
absolute dependence didn't change
similarly from endoderm to the random
coordinate descent enter them the d
dependence have some dependencies even
worse
so you can argue that we to get an upper
bound that's easy right you just do a
fuzzy job
but you can find the counter example
that shows this random coordinate
decision version of entertainment is
really just bad if you move one gaussian
to a different gaussian this is a simple
sampling algorithm the sampling problem
that you can imagine moving from one
gaussian to another gaussian if you
follow step by step using the
entertainment random code in a decent
version of entertainment the cost is
this much and this is exactly the same
cost as the classical underdamped
laundry multicolor so there's no way
that you can win
and we want to see
why it's bad
so
in this whole business of sampling
the mechanism or the the techniques that
we use is a coupling method so you
develop two trajectories
one trajectory i call it x
that follows the algorithm
and one trajectory i call it y it
follows the stochastic differential
equation the language dynamics and you
compare this to a trajectory and you
hope these two trajectory contract in
some sense
so
i call this distance y and x by delta
and i just expand it out and i find out
that the new iteration delta
equals to the old iteration delta with
some other terms
and we look at these terms they can be
glued into three categories
this term is a good term
you pull out this mu and this gives you
one minus mu h so this is a contracting
term
and you hope to keep it there
and this term essentially comes from
discretization you discretize your that
the conv you discretize your
lender dynamics into smaller chunks now
of course you're paying some
discretization error and this is not our
contribution we just copy paste it from
the previous result
so what we need to do is to bound this
area
this is the error that you get when you
replace the gradient by the random
coordinate version of the approximation
so our job is to make sure that this
term
is going to be
somewhat negligible
compared to the discretization
and we put it into our chart
and we find out that this error term
when you have the classical language
color of course this term is zero but if
you replace it by the gradient descent
this is the amount of errors that you
accumulate h is the step size d is the
dimensionality it is much larger than
the discretization error that you see
so of course it brings more error that
drives up your cost
and we think a little bit more of this
term
so this term is you replace the gradient
by the random coordinate version of the
gradient
so each time you pick a random
coordinate to represent the full thing
on average you truly represent but that
introduced a lot of variance
this high variance
sounds somewhat similar
and we have experienced it
in optimization again
in optimization especially in stochastic
gradient descent
when you're in stochastic gradient
descent the objective function is the
summation for bunch therefore the
gradient is the summation of a bench so
in each iteration you randomly pick one
coordinate and one one representative to
represent the full gradient
so on average you represent the real
gradient but this random process
gives you the high variance
so there are so there are variation
reduction techniques that is to control
this variance one example is the johnson
jump this is to say that once in a while
you compute the true gradient
but in each sub iterations in between
you just randomly pick one sub function
to update it to get the true gradient
there
so we follow the same idea we are
viewing the gradient as a summation of a
bunch of partial derivative and we say
that every once in a while you compute
the true gradient and in the sub steps
you just randomly pick one coordinate
and update only one particular
coordinate the hope is
every once in a while you get the true
gradient so at least for this particular
step the variance is zero
and in between you're sort of controlled
so we we so
so all these strategies we just borrow
it from johnson and we find out the meal
of course is zero and we need to control
the variance
a different strategy is saga
stochastic averaging gradient whatever
this a stands for
it also says the same thing initially
you have to prepare the true gradient
and in the following steps every once
you in the following step in each
iteration you just update one you choose
one coordinate to update it and all that
everybody else you keep you keep the
same you keep the history basically
and they borrow the same technique so
now we
inherit this variance reduction
technique into the random code in a
decent version of laundry monte carlo
let's see what will happen to the
variance
the variance
is reduced the h dependence is increased
so this is good
this area is comparable to the
discretization error in particular this
is the area that you cumulate per step
and you cumulate a lot of steps so when
h drops out that basically tells you
that this is the number of iterations
three halves is the number of iterations
you have to pay for excellent accuracy
so we glue everything together and this
is our final result
for the over damped case
in terms of the cost
if you just replace the gradient by the
partial derivative the cost is not
reduced
however if you incorporate the variance
reduction technique into random
coordinates and lmc
this is your cause in both d demand d
dependence and absolute dependence is
improved
the same story can be said for the under
damped for the internet i particularly
want to emphasize this particular term
so this is a term
when epsilon very small this term
dominant and you are basically looking
at the cost the cost of under the length
of a multicolor is d square root
um
although we don't have we cannot show
the optimality
but it's it's very hard to imagine that
you can
improve yeah
what when you use these variants
reduction techniques like at each step
you are you're um using like
approximation of the full gradient so
wouldn't the cost of each iteration now
scale as do you
sorry so can you say that again all
right
correct me if i'm wrong but if you use
like a very introduction technique then
each time you're using an approximation
for the full gradient yes so does that
mean like each iteration now costs uh d
time
um no you only update one partial
derivative but when you do the longevity
step don't you
oh right so so it depends on what you
call how what do you mean by a cost so
if each
if each coordinate gets updated that's a
cost then you are right and each
coordinate get update but the problem is
i think to me
computing the partial derivative itself
is is a cost
so now you're only updating one so
everybody else still kept the same
okay yeah i agree in terms of like the
number of uh great gradient evaluations
this saves okay done okay thank you
thank you
maybe your point is that in svrg every
now and again you evaluate a full
gradient right
and then in between you just go you just
evaluate one component
so the ones where you evaluate a full
gradient you should count that as a cost
of d
step itself
since you're adding like an
approximation of the full grain you're
actually updating all the coordinates
and stuff
yeah so so so that component of the cost
we don't really care that
yeah
so okay so so i'm i'm i'm really happy
with the d square root for the cost
um so that's a lot of algorithms so let
me summarize it a little bit for both
over damped and under damped laundry
multi-color you move from
the classical uh landry monte carlo to
the reduced uh sorry the
random coordinate version of the laundry
monte carlo in terms of the d and
absolute dependence you do not see any
improvement the improvement can be seen
only in the conditioning of the problem
depending on l versus l max
however
if you say that in each iteration you
only update one coordinate and everybody
else do not fluctuate you get the random
coordinate descent
sorry what i'm saying um
so in each iteration
uh eric everybody fluctuate but you only
update one coordinate
when that happens you have the random
coordinate version of it you get the
worst result however if you incorporate
various reduction technique to the worst
result it drags you down to the better
performance
so that's a take-home message
um
it's included in three papers
um the first paper is about the variance
reduction it's recently accepted and i
highly doubt the
reviewer is probably one of us
and the second and third paper is the
random coordinate version of the lmc
thank you very much
okay any questions
yeah so go back to the previous question
on the bias so what so i'm really
wondering what's the
h20 limit of these randomized coordinate
designs because so if you think about
the original
over them or not under them landline
dynamics it's
of course a converges both of them
converge exponentially fast but
you are in some sense you are
alternating the
dynamics so
when you think about the h go to zero
limit it's no longer the
it's no longer the precise dynamics so i
will guess it induces bias and also
does this still converge exponentially
um
okay so you're talking about the
underdamped uh the the random coordinate
version of the android dental endurance
dynamics
both over them
but the h goes to zero limit really yeah
so so the dynamics not the algorithm
yeah yeah right right so we do not have
the exponential convergence
but we can prove its coverage
we don't have the rate
so what's so what's so why is that
happening so why can we why do we have
that day converge exponentially in the
discrimination level
oh no no no well i i should say that the
language dynamics it converges but we do
not have the technique to prove the
convergence rate is exponential
yes so basically i think the problem
here is if you simply let h go to zero
then definitely this rc lmc will
converge to the right limit so basically
the over damped
launchpad diffusion equation so
reason is
if you think h is very
small then basically
you can your randomly choose the
coordinate this phenomenon where dick
will disappear
and
however i think the right quest and the
right question to
to ask is so basically now you let h go
to zero then
then from some
time interval delta t
you use the same call and you use a
random coordinator to update
so basically you need to add another
delta t here into a system then you will
have a different continuous limit and
instead in
in set case we
i think we still have the exponential
convergence rate but we don't know the
date
yeah
that says answer question
okay okay
any other any other questions
um have you thought about the the
randomized midpoint discretization
yes
no we haven't been able to figure out
anything but that yeah so that that's a
very good yeah that's a very good result
um we don't know how to use it
maybe i just have a question um
so you you said that when you do the rcd
where you add noise onto everything
can't you just
scale that noise by a factor of d
and then ultimately you'll sort of have
the same expected effect as adding noise
to a single component uh
just divide by d and i mean
[Music]
or do you keep that noise parameter the
same
in rcd as you have for full gradient
yeah
um
we haven't we have not thought about
that okay
yeah but that's right that's one of the
methods she analyzes is
it's like that but i'm saying that the
objection that chin raised to that was
that um
you would be yeah okay
okay
uh well
thank you very much again and thanks to
all the speakers this afternoon for a
great session
[Applause]
okay sir